[Music]
hello and warm welcome from my side uh
my name is Mark duop I'm the managing
director of Nova sign gmbh uh welcome to
this session today today we're going to
talk about digital twins uh before we
start talking about digital twins for
bioprocessing I quickly want to
introduce novas sign to you basically so
novas sign is a spin-off from Boku
University in Vienna so B university is
in a university that has a department
for biotechnology since 30 years and uh
in this department of biotechnology we
always focus on uh accelerating
bioprocess development and something
like five to six six years ago actually
we thought about how can we make things
better and how can we use machine
learning in order to accelerate this
process even further uh based on that we
founded the company novasan in 2019 with
the aim is set to speed up the
development process and we already have
quite some customers that use our Tools
in order to accelerate this development
so now coming to a digital twin I mean
some of you including me uh might
already be fed up by the word digital
twin because digital twin can be
anything or nothing so what is a digital
twin what should it do and that's often
quite unclear so you have to be quite
precise in when you talk about digital
twins what is actually the aim of a
digital twin and what should it do so in
order to shed light in what I understand
in the digital twin or what a digital
towin for bioprocess can potentially
help you I want to guide you through
with a with a high level overview and
then we go into some use cases to to get
some details about what you can do with
these tools and why it will be
beneficial to implement such tools in
the future so starting off very easily
uh you might notice 4p model so the 4p
model basically describes if you have a
certain patient that has a certain
medical need uh this patient needs for
sure a certain product okay so there's a
request from the patient to the product
and the product for sure has a request
for the process and the process itself
has a request for the plant so basically
these are these four things that are
connected and if you go the the direct
the other direction basically the plant
has to fit the process the process has
to fit the product and the product has
to fit the patient so easy as that and
currently there's a lot there are a lot
of initiatives to uh for a digital
transformation of all of these all of
these things and a lot of companies like
Google are investing in the in the
interface between the patients and the
product and other companies for example
that are more into plant engineering and
building up facilities there are more in
the interface between the plant and the
process so now in order to talk about
digital bioprocess or digital twins for
bioprocessing I consider this to be in
the interface between the process and
the product so basically what we want to
mimic what we want to create is a
digital
representation uh of the interface
between the process and the product so
now what should this thing do it it
should basically be an insilico
representation as I already said of
exactly this process and product
dependency it should basically help you
to understand uh the relation between
your critical process parameters and
your critical material attributes to
your critical quality attributes this is
what what it should help you to
understand and at the end it must have
and this is prerequisite of a digital
twin to have a real time connection to
the process itself in order to control
it so that means you have this
understanding digital twin and then this
digital twin should directly or must
directly interfere with your process in
order to do something to control
something and now the question is what
can we actually do and this I will
highlight in the next in the next slides
so what are the potentials of a digital
twin uh how we at novas sign basically
Envision a digital twin it should be in
the center so the digital twin should be
in the center and should be a process
representation as I just showed you so
in order to uh basically train this
digital twin to be able to be a digital
representation of something yeah for
sure we have to perform experiments so
there are experiments that are performed
in early or late stage process
development and from this data we
basically train the digital twin and
then the digital twin should give us
process understanding and from this
process understanding then we take the
decision how to set up the process the
ideal way and afterwards we taken and
that's important uh to transfer this
knowledge for process control and scale
up so by doing so the idea is to have a
sorry that the digital TR basically
follows the product life cycle of a
product early stage development late
stage
development sorry and afterwards uh
using the same digital TN for scale up
and and control so that is the vision
here from the perspective of what it
should deliver to you at the end so yeah
if we think about early stage
development you can do a lot of
different experiments you can do a lot
of changes in in your process and all of
these different processes they lead to
different results so if you plot the
response on the
y-axis and let's say the response is for
example certain product quality or a
certain product amount you see that
depending on how you set up your process
all of these processes Le to different
quality to different titles so the aim
basically is I'm
sorry the aim basically is to find the
process at the end that delivers the
highest product quality or the highest
uh product am so this would be something
where digital T couldn't be used in uh
the laboratory in the early stage
development to exactly identify this
ideal processes ideally in silico and
then you just take this in silico
suggestion perform the experiment and
ideally you you end up at exactly that
point what the digital twin suggested
you the second thing then when you think
about later in the process or when you
think about using the digital twn for
manufacturing
purposes sorry is about always
maintaining the same product quality or
the same product amount so when you
think about okay this is now our ideal
process we identify this how do we Now
operate it always to get the same
product outcome so if you now have a
Seto process normally if you perform
this process over and over again you get
quite likely the same results but
sometimes it might also happen that that
you see during your process that we're
ending up somewhere completely different
and another questions who everyone knows
when looking at the kpis in this process
right now okay something is going wrong
but now the the the the request for the
digital twin or the the task it should
fulfill is basically to bring back this
process and to bring back the quality
where it should be so to change the
process parameter in order to get back
to the desired quality and this can be
seen as a model predictive control
approach in today I will show you both
showcases for the first case for the
process optimization and also for this
control purposes so how can we basically
control our process by means of a
digital twin
uh so what can it deliver as said
different perspective but same picture
um faster process understanding so we
want to reduce experimental effort to
describe a certain design space in the
qbd concept we want to use this process
knowledge or this process models during
scaleup uh to basically take this
learning from the small scale and bring
it to the larg scale and finally we uh
want to use the type of models for
process control purposes so what I just
showed you okay something goes wrong how
can we interact with the process in
order to get to the desired
quality uh how is the workflow to
deliver such a digital twin it's
actually quite simple but it has to be
clearly defined so you have to start
with a goal uh if you talk about digital
twins for the sake of talking about
digital twins it's nice to have a
password but at the end you really have
to say what is the purpose of the
digital twin and what should it do so if
you say Okay I want to optimize okay I
want to control it's a clear purpose and
then you have to say okay in which range
with which factors and so on and so for
you really have to clearly Define what
the digital twin should do and based on
that you can then uh start considering
the experiments you have to perform
based on that you collect data so all of
these experiment they basically deliver
you a lot of data from this data you can
set up a process model that should
describe this this data and then you put
this process model in a digital toin
where you can do in silico simulations
to say what would happen if so what
would happen if we now change the
temperature what would happen if we
change the pH etc etc and the digital
twin would basically suggest you new
experiments so you can see this as an
iterative Loop you define a goal you
create experiments you create you select
data from that you create a process
model the process model is put into the
digital twin then you get suggestions
for ideal process conditions oops wrong
button and then basically the digital
twin either suggest your new experiments
or when you're happy with the results
you can basically take this knowledge
and as I showed you before transfer it
for for the for upscale or or use it for
the manufacturing directly depending on
where you perform this this knowledge uh
for that purpose we have developed the
hybrid modeling toolbox at novas sign uh
you can also use it so if you have your
smartphone you can simply scan this QR
code here and you can start using it for
free so it's a premium concept you can
you can start modeling your process uh
with that tool and if you're interested
you can always get back to us and we can
also help you to to set it up the right
way so this basically uh hybrid modeling
toolbox with the digital twin Inu helps
you to get time resolve process models
so for upstream and downstream and it's
used for optimization purposes and you
can use it afterwards as said for
control and this is what I will show you
now in the next uh 20 minutes when we
talk about Hybrid models that's
something you might be unaware of what
is a hybrid model basically so a hybrid
model does exactly the same task as all
of the other models you have something
to describe so let's say you're
interested in describing a critical
quality attributes let's say we have two
here critical quality attribute one and
two and we want to describe them as a
function of several critical process
parameters or critical material
attributes inputs uh the way how it
works is that you have two uh different
model structures that are connected
somehow with each other in our case for
the Upstream it's a it's a Serial hybrid
model so we have some mechanistic
equations mechanistic equations that
simply describe for example cell growth
or uh
production of of an antibody or
production of an A or whatever you're
looking at in your process and then we
have a machine learning part in our case
an artificial neural network that uh
describes the rates and the unknowns in
this in these mechanistic equations and
by connecting this basically these two
worlds together you get a very price
precise identification uh of your design
space with a small number of experiments
you can uh you can use this knowledge
for process scale up and as said due to
the structure of the model and this is
what I will show you afterwards is you
can take this type of model and
integrate it directly for control
purposes uh one of the Publications we
have in that direction is basically a
comparison between a pure mechanistic
model and the hybrid model to describe a
CH cell date CH cell culture and what I
want to empathize here is the difference
of of how this two type of model works
so when you look at the mechanistic
model a mechanistic model has a a strong
buil backbone where you basically have a
certain assumption that defines the
model structure and it's quite
independent of the data and you will see
now I have four different data
distributions and you will see how how
the model changes over the different
data distributions from the mechanistic
model and from the hybrid model the
hybrid model and mechanistic model here
if you take four initial experiments in
this case in this publication which
where the link you can follow down there
we had a five-dimensional design space
with over 100 experiments and the data
points you see in here are from 38
experiments I guess you see that if you
have initial four experiments and you
don't really choose this experiment
wisely you see that both models are not
very accurate so if you now choose
optimal for experiments and this is
where this Loop of process modeling what
I described you before comes into play
if you if you think about how you do
this then you see that the hybrid model
already very precisely uh describes the
whole design space and here when I talk
about design space the of this here is
to describe the product formation of an
antibody uh in the chel culture but when
you look at the mechanistic model you
see that basically the the um how to say
the model efficiency is the is very
similar to the initial four experiment
so that means the the model is as good
or as bad from the very first point and
it doesn't actually need any data point
or doesn't need data in order to to be
trains you see it works very very
similarly yeah then you can iterate this
through you can say okay now here we
have 19 experiments and you see the
hybrid model yeah gets better but also
not a lot better and the same applies
for the for the mechanistic model so in
a nutshell at the end what you can see
is if you perform four very clever
experiments so in terms of clever you
Choose Wisely which per which
experiments you do and you have a model
like a hybrid model you can describe
this design space quite accurately and
that means this model covers the nature
of the process intrinsically and then
you can use this type of model to
simulate all of the different process
condition and optimize your process at
the end so just if you want to look at
this again so I want to empathize here
we have only four experiments here we
have 35 experiments to the right hand
side where is the age and basically what
you see is that you can describe uh the
product formation quite accurately or
similarly with both of these data
distributions while on the left hand
side you only performed four four
experiments yeah so you can save a lot
of experiments by that in process
development you don't need a lot of
prior knowledge because the the hybrid
model has a rigid structure in the back
end but learns from data straight away
so it can easily be applied and you see
that the that the that the description
here on this data set is better than the
mechanistic model apart from the First
Data distribution I would say so now
when you come about use cases how can we
now apply such a hybrid model or or or a
digital twin in order to describe the
design spaces uh we have several
approaches how we can perform
experiments and how we can extract this
dat data so one of the things here I
want to empathize is uh model based
design of experiments it's also
something we published down there and
what you basically do is uh you are
following this uh workflow I showed you
previously so you start with a certain
objective okay you want to describe uh
space time yield you want to describe
dilation whatsoever you have a clear aim
of what your model should deliver you
start with some initial experiments you
create a hybrid model based on that the
hybrid model is put into the digital
dwin and then we can do almost uh free
of charge we can click the button and
simulate thousands 10 thousands of
different cultivations in silico and
then the tool tells you what is the best
condition to be performed and then you
look at uh at the result and the result
is either a new Optimum so that means
the tool predicts a certain process
which you did not perform in the in the
lab then you can go back or a certain
set of experiments and you can go back
in the lab and then perform it or to a
certain extent at a certain time point
then basically the the tool does not
predict the new Optimum and then
basically you are finished with your
optimization
process with that you can iterate
through the design space quite quickly
and you can save a lot of experimental
effort and also this was already
published down there uh it's a simple
workflow from experiment to data to
model to knowledge because all of that
is basically covered in the digital twin
and all of this knowledge is stored so
and and a new employee can open this
tool look at the look at the process
model can play with it and can
understand okay how temperature how
feeding rate how whatever
oxy dissolved oxygen really affects your
process uh with in terms of with respect
to productivity or glycosilation or
whatever is the case you or the is the
is the factor you want to
optimize the other thing I want to show
you is something what this is more for
late stage uh processes so when you are
in the larger bioreactor and you want to
characterize your process so to prove in
Fr in front of the authorities okay I
have to characterize what's happening
around of my Optimum
what is happening if I operate at one or
two degrees more or less how can I
basically describe this faster than
performing all of this experiment
sequentially so when you look at this
for example this is a this data here is
from eoli Cas study from a 20 L
bioreactor and each of these points
represents one experiment so we have a
three dimensional design space with
three levels that means 3 to the^ 3 27
experiments and if you would now do this
process characterization on the larger
scale you most likely have only bio one
bioreactor and that would mean you would
take almost like half a year just
performing this experiments in order to
understand what is happening in there so
it's quite time consuming the thing we
want to suggest here is is this
intensify Des kind of experiment
approach where you dynamically change
process parameters so you can think
about this like you start with one of
these points and then they are connected
by this lines and everything that's
connected is basically one experiment so
rather than performing just one point is
one experiment here we Peck something
like three experiments in a single
experiment that what you that's what you
see here basically so we start from the
top left corner go to the center and
then go to the bottom left corner and
this is one experiment by doing so you
can pick multiple unit uh you can pick
multiple experiments into a single
experiment and by that basically are
able to describe the design space much
faster so rather than doing 27
experiments in this case we only perform
uh N9 experiments and now how does this
basically uh unscramble at the end when
you look in the center or when you look
at this graph uh in the center let's say
where this where this point cloud is uh
you see there is a prediction and there
is a measurement and the prediction
basically describes what the model
predicts you and the measurement is
everything you you you you describe by
means of yeah measuring yeah so and the
point is if if both of these if all of
these points are on the DI diagonal line
that means your model perfectly
describes your data and what we did here
is we created a hybrid model based on
this intensified runs so what I showed
you to the left we changed process
parameters dynamically and basically
applied this model then on the static
conditions so that means when you now uh
train your model on only 213
observations coming from nine
experiments you see how this model in
orange or how this uh data in orage and
the model based on that is able to
precisely predict what is happening in
the test St data which is this um
greenish greenish triangles apart from
some of these runs which are not
predicted very well the majority of the
data is really predicted in in a very
good way and what this basically tells
is you can use nine experiments doing
Dynamic experiments learn from that and
apply this model on 27 static
experiments and the the two graphs to
the right are basically example of this
validation data which is ordinary doe
data where nothing was changed in the
process and you can see how
model which was trained on idid can very
precisely predict what is happening
inside this design space so in a
nutshell you can significantly save
experimental effort for process
characterization and also this was also
published so you see two links here the
first one is from this show case study
and the second one basically is a
publication we just published together
with buringer inham where they performed
the same approach in ch cell culture
basically and uh a similar gives you a
similar picture about that so what does
it mean yes you can save up to 70% of
experiments at least how we see this
right now maybe you can save even more
but this IDE is still uh in a very early
shoes so if you want to try it out just
R the application and and consider how
you want to how you want to create your
models yourself I think that's a very
promising approach for the future to
faster learn from experiments so not
just perform static experiments but
really introducing the Dynamics changing
processes and therefore learning more in
the development and maybe also
potentially in the future setting up
processes like I mean no one says that a
process must have constant parameters
you can also change temperature feeding
rates whatsoever dynamically over the
time course if if this yields to higher
productivity lower gly illation
whatsoever uh it's a very streamlined
workflow you come from experiment to
data to model to knowledge the same as
before and as I already said it's
already currently in used uh also at the
first uh pharmaceutical
companies okay now coming to the process
control side how can we now use these
models uh not only to optimize an early
stage but also then to use it for
process control on the on the on the
manufacturing site so here for example
we have a collaboration with seens
together in Vienna so this is a picture
of the Sean living lab in Vienna so you
see there's a small bio reactor to the
back and what we wanted to do here is we
wanted to create a soft sensor based on
a doe where we changed pH and
temperature and at the end the soft
sensor should predict the current
biomass in the in the bio Rector without
directly measuring the biomass in the in
the in the bio Rector and the
application for something like this
would be to uh create soft sensor that
says okay now you have 2 G per liter 3 G
six G per liter and based on that you
can then take decisions like um in
induction of cells transection of cells
harvesting of cells whatsoever can be
taken so if you look at how this works
so we characterized the design space we
created a process model and now we take
took
a validation data so a complete
different uh run and what you see is you
how the hybrid model uh predicts quite
accurately what's basically the current
biomass concentration in your bio Rector
which is this red line based on the pH
the temperature and the current offcast
measurement and then you for sure for
validation purposes we also performed
cell dry weight sampling so we sampled
and put it on the on a balance and after
after drying the biomass and you can see
how accurate the soft sensor is so by
that as said you get a quite precise
prediction of biomass at each time point
and you can take something like that for
for decision making during a cultivation
run
yeah the next thing which is even more
advanced is a model predictive
controller so that means here now really
the digital t comes back and say okay
now I want to control my process I learn
from the process I know how input and
output is connected now I really want to
control my process that is the
ultimative goal of a digital twin in the
manufacturing side and here basically
what we did is we took the same showcase
I showed you before for this idoe
showcase so the the microbial 20 L
cultivation and we simulated the pump
failure now so now imagine you're in the
production site everything is running
smoothly and suddenly your your feet
pump fails whatsoever your feet pump
fails you don't get any feeding to your
Sal so quite not that good yeah and what
you will see now is how this model
predictive controller automatically
takes decision to recover the process so
to take action and to say okay if I now
change that and that than that process
parameter I will still yield the same
product amount at the end of the
cultivation this is what is the aim of
this MPC approach here so when looking
at this uh you have you see five
different figures uh on the left hand
side the three figures are the the input
parameters namely the feet volume the
temperature and the inductor Mass so
it's a microbial process we're into
we're in inducing this with ipg and what
you now see is basically here we have a
pump failure so we see no feeding
anymore and from the lines I want to go
through and help you basically the blue
line is the optimum offline uh
conditions the blue one is basically the
process how it should run and then we
see the green one is the no control
group so that means we have a pump
filion afterwards we just continue as we
did before and the the purple one is the
MPC so basically the the tool that can
automatically take actions and you also
see the the the control borders in which
the MPC can take action so you see not
to that the NPC just doesn't do whatever
he likes we put some restriction of what
the NPC is allowed to automatically do
and what you see basically that the NPC
until we are still on the same on the on
the ideal trajectory it doesn't take any
action okay now here we introduce the
the pump failure at seven hours and then
the NPC can take decisions to say okay
there's something wrong we have to do
something about it and then the NPC
takes action changes the temperature and
significantly changes the amount of
induct the feed to the cell so the NPC
understood okay if we have less cell we
have to induce them more in order to get
the same amount of product out so this
is a thing that the NPC learned from the
data we we did not tell him or it per se
it learned this from the data and it
took the decision itself to control the
process and then once this pump failure
was fixed 3 hours later then basically
the NPC starts overfeeding so
significantly starts overfeeding as you
see from the top left uh uh image that
the trajectory of the feet is
significantly increased and by
significantly increasing this trajectory
of the feet uh basically you can also
see to the top right how the biomass
catches up again so while the biomass in
the in the time where there was no feed
really starts to decrease not not good
you can afterwards see basically how the
biomass how the biomass catches up again
and then at the end also overshoots the
the overall biomass concentration
because we reach the the maximum feed at
an at an earlier time but what you can
actually not see is the difference
between the optimum offline control and
the MPC because the NPC takes action uh
automatically and you see that they are
still overlapping so what you can learn
from this data is basically or from this
showcase is that the MPC could uh
maintain the same amount of product we
were searching for at the end of the
process although we had the significant
process uh interference which is which
comes from the from the pump failure and
that at the end is where we envision an
MPC or a digital twin can unfold its
full potential so we we use it for
learning we train faster we find our
Optimum faster and afterwards we take it
for process control and and monitoring
and this is basically the ultimative uh
test for something like that to say okay
we have a change what can we basically
do the the limitation we have for sure
is that only changes in the input
parameter can be can be compens at so if
you have something completely different
which your model is not built on yeah
modeling the unknown unknowns is
difficult therefore you will not be able
to cope with that and therefore again
it's important to think what what are
likely events which factors do I have to
incorporate and it's like always in life
the better you plan plan up front the
less issues you have afterwards last
thing I want to empathize here is a
project where currently running it's
called a Conti where it's about to
create a fully integrated automated onto
biom manufacturing platform and what we
basically do is we want to build the
first eoli based platform that should
continuously produce uh protein a in
this case it's just a a showcase protein
we can replace this afterwards with
other proteins but the idea is here we
have a cell line that um due to the
process how we set it up with two chats
connected to each other we basically can
overcome the problem of mutations over
the time and what you see is we have
after these two chem starts we have a
primary recovery filtration unit and
then an system from too comes in uh a
multicolumn chromatography system and
afterwards we basically get product out
at the at the constant flow rate and the
way how we do this is basically we work
together with cubicon they are
collecting the data and on cubicon on
top basically Nova sign and Santage
build on Santage is a company focusing
on cftd modeling while we as Nova sign
focusing on on the whole end to end
process and we will basically build this
MPC concept here in this in this whole
unit operations so we have only four
unit operations two Upstream two
Downstream but at the end the idea here
on division is to fully control this
process and this is something we're
currently we're currently working on so
what comes together is the physical
world again with the digital world so we
want to digitalize this process optimize
it in silico digital twin approach and
then go back and use it for control
purposes and this is exactly uh what is
currently happening in this
process so now in order to conclude my
talk uh whenever you talk about digital
twins it's important to consider first
what the digital twin is and what it
should deliver digital twins are
anything and nothing they for sure have
a very high potential for the future you
just have to really consider what it
should do and how you get there in order
to do that consider the whole modeling
workflow rather than just talking about
the very fancy process model or so it's
really about everything the experiments
are as important as important as the as
the modeling approach uh the Hybrid
models themselves they're a very sound
basis to build such a digital twin so
they are can learn on only a little
amount of data so that's really cool and
uh the digital twin then can help you to
optimize up and downstream today I only
showed you Upstream but if you're
interested you can always reach out we
also have a lot of Downstream
applications in order to save
experiments you should combine uh Hybrid
models with a and ID depending on what
you're aiming for and at the end to
really make the most out of that not
just stop in a development department
take the digital train along the whole
process life cycle and then use it as a
as a modative controller for example at
the End by integrating it into a control
system with that I'm at the end of my
presentation I want to thank you for
your time if you want to reach out
either uh yeah reach me out on LinkedIn
or send me an email I'm happy to answer
all of your questions and yeah I wish
you a very productive conference and
have a great day
bye